let it work
psycho position we have fabian and
caruana world number two after winning
his game and smashing style fabi before
we get to your game
this one has been chaotic what's your
feeling about this position
um
well if black takes on f3
knight takes bishop f6 or or there's
bishop c it looks like black is the one
who's deciding because he can play
bishop c3 or something and and it should
be close to equal
so the question is does he have
something else um
i mean there's queen c2 but
let's bring up the board yes yeah i got
it we got it there's queen c2 fabi just
continue i guess it's oops but your snap
instinct would say black's okay
is certainly okay
white is probably also okay
geez
how come it doesn't
go go go go
such a hard work rookie five okay it
should be seven and queen b3
b7 maybe also queen e2 i don't know
it's uh
queen b3 also but okay it should be
should be very close to equal
okay this allows queen c6 with some
because then f3 queen b6 and rook b4
um
i mean you'd you'd take black
but you'd probably bet on a draw
richard with 30 seconds by the way i've
just been told
and
what's your instinct that he's going to
do what he took on c2 ah my instinct is
that he's going to take on c2 yeah thank
you
uh i probably mentioned b7
there was bishop g32 fabi he took on c2
but he could have also considered bishop
g3 we do have queen c2 and rook e5 on
the board we have four
moves for black to make
with 34 seconds on the clock he did play
bishop b7
chakra did play queen
back to b3 and there is a queen c6
possibility i mean he's going to play
queen c6 i i would just queen b3 is a
draw and queen c6 f3 queen b6 and rook
b4 is dangerous for white so
it's uh probably a no-brainer that black
black's queens come back and play for
that position
rook h2 ideas after this queen c6 this
is a great thing you have to play f3 f3
right yeah
i mean he's down to how many seconds
twenty seven remember they get another
thirty seconds every time they make a
move so it's not like they wrap it on
blitz
here he could just take on d3 and drone
button
where'd that come from we liked
provoking the move f3 queen c7 not queen
c6
but it allows rook c5 i i don't
yeah why i get it actually that's a
shocker
in the moment when oh you've got a thing
rook c5 rook h2
this is his idea
[Music]
what a gorgeous move why did we put our
queen on c7 so that when the king comes
to h2
we have this one
it turns out that's not true because of
knight f3
what
after rook h2 there's knight f3 i
thought there was rook g3 but king h2
the pins don't uh matter at all
rook g3 otherwise would be very strong
but king h2 and uh
oh my goodness the blunder is waiting
something bad oh
oh wow look at this c5 rook h
you can see richard's jacket shaking
his leg is shaking underneath his leg
but that's the queen he's reaching for
queen b2 played he said he's retreated
as queen
what a position by the way queesy seven
ninjas giving rook c5 queen at four
truly psycho move oh my goodness that
would have been something else i see on
the board and have they made time no no
no no no no no no no no
more moves to make shotgun just one more
yeah but he's back okay yeah and that
queen b2 x-raying on the rook
on h a on h8 while stopping these rook
h4 checkmating ideas
richard needs to find a move he has 14
seconds left and counting maybe he'll
play like king g8 just to
he's not sure look at this his time is
ticking down he's under 10 seconds he's
got to move dad move something
oh
one second why do you notice to us one
second one
31 you're absolutely right you get a 30
second bonus one more move for shaq
he completed his move with one second on
screen all right roxy five now probably
a little bit stronger than last time
rook h2 does not work at all because the
queen is covering h8 right so what do
you play against rook c5
you are busted
busted busted
well you play queen d6 it's not
immediately game over it looks very bad
but uh
anything to be said for rook c1 no
no rook c1
but rooks he won't allow zork h2 yeah
then we're h2 because the queen is not
covering the hh correct correct correct
rook c5 stopping rook h2 which might
still be losing for black because of 94
or some something like that but some
gross movement but he's got 29 seconds
to figure it out oh no
we're gonna get another 30 second
is he gonna play rook c5
oof tense moment here 19 seconds for one
move by what a crucial move it is and
black will have to play his next
movement how many seconds
it's 12 it's 11 seconds he's got to move
he's playing every three instead i see
you frowning on every move by the way
fabian you're like what are they doing
oh no no i mean these moves seem so they
just feel wrong like rook g8 feels
horribly wrong mm-hmm i mean rook
for g eight like if you wanted to listen
i'm sorry let's get back to the board
though because he's gotta make his 40th
move his clock is ticking down so you
can keep speaking ten
nine and sean
seven seconds
five four
got to make a move and he's playing f
six
totally lost
what no rookie sex rook g3's idea but
maybe because yeah i think f1 is strong
yeah it's over rookie six must be
winning rookie six is winning shakurya
is all the time in the world to figure
it out
and poor richard is gonna go down in
this game the time pressure as we said
time is such a factor and it will just
make fools of us all
wow wow
what a sequence that was fabi thanks so
much for for humoring us tolerate
we couldn't get away from this game and
just interview you because it was such a
dynamic moment but now we have some time
let's talk about your game that you had
it was a big victory this opening you
played let's get it on the board the
opening you played you played very fast
actually uh he has it
yasha will have it here you play very
quickly the move g3 this position was
known
your your clear preparation your
feelings about this kind of position you
got here we go
no i i didn't prepare this line i i mean
i played this in 2013 against boris
gelfand and i didn't expect it today and
i
just played what i had looked at
eight years ago
yeah
the fact you could remember it's
impressive
but it's years ago it's it's just a
setup like there's not there are no
concrete variations here so
there's not too much to remember you
just have to
uh to know that you can play this line
um
rookie it turned out to be a novelty
according to maurice's database we've
seen
the move rook d8 a6 even f5 i don't know
d6 d6 these things are theater
where did things start going really well
in your estimation when were you
satisfied that you've got a good
position yeah it was a very tough
position to play uh because oh by the
way were you aware that right here the
computer has a really great suggestion
for your opponent
what is it h5 oh close h5 is a good move
h5 is a good move yes that's logical but
that's not the move
mike what what
what what
what
this happened all day to us fabby today
i mean the engine was making moves like
we couldn't explain whatsoever yeah
bishop b2 i didn't
that wasn't on your radar either yeah
no
here we weren't completely satisfied
with the move knight b6
we kind of felt that he was heading in
the wrong direction
and forcing this uh you felt good about
this whole attack well knight b6 did
surprise me um i was actually thinking
his idea would be to play h5 here
um just to try to
uh fix my pawns because the bishop is
bishop b4 right um
but of course it's also like it allows
queen g2 and then g4 and a very
sharp position so i can understand why
he didn't want to allow this attack
um g4 is not there's also e5 there's
various moves but but g4 and yeah i
understand why he didn't want to go for
this
um
but knight b6 felt like a bad square for
the knight it just feels very awkward um
but his idea was concrete and it made
sense um
i think here after f5 he should not play
e takes f5
he should play
um i was thinking about dc4 um
because fe 6 iv6 is not i mean it's
dangerous but it's not like i have a
very clear follow up
i was actually thinking maybe
dc4 bishop h5
uh with the idea rookie one bishop f7 i
think is very strong
if he goes for that because i actually
uh
yeah it looks like a nice that queen if
seven comes in rook d1 yeah so
so i understand also why he
he was worried about not like he wanted
a more stable position but it
ends up being extremely positionally
dangerous because
um what did you have a bishop d6 instead
of ef5
i didn't look at bishop d6
i don't know that move just didn't occur
to me like you look at d4 dc4 ef5 and d4
but you don't look at moves which don't
keep the tension greg
we all know and love would say maintain
the tension find the move that maintains
the tension bishop d6 is one of those
kind of moves i don't think anybody it
might be a brilliant i mean i assume
it's a very good move um
but i didn't consider it yeah here i was
just very happy because
uh
like long term at some point my pawns
will start to roll c5 is too weak as
bishop is is just a disaster
um
so i assumed it was
close to
winning much better maybe
not easy but but much better for sure
yeah of course he shouldn't allow b4 but
uh
but it's difficult because if i get
knight d3 then b4 is coming anyway i
mean
yeah a5 of course he should play this
move
and uh just about here everything was
going your way and
this was a very nice move knight h5 you
saw this from afar
well when i played rookie two yeah it
was uh because it's not clear what else
is natural for him to do besides knight
g4 there's no obvious moves
queen b3 rookie one is is losing so
well thus far it really had the feeling
of a very smooth game and these pawns
spoke for themselves connected pass
bonds i i thought he still had some
chance to put up resistance with queen
c2 bishop e6 is just a bad move
basically
um
and
i was going to play c6 but
it is sort of scary because there's
rookie 2 and i have knight f4 but
you know low on time you you start to
see some ghosts but i um i thought my
pawns should win i didn't see exactly
how his attack is working out
very nice this one
for the brilliancy prize versus the last
one you won
was there anything brilliant in this
game all right i'm just just checking
you guys are the judges you tell me yeah
no we thought you rolled him yeah this
was this wasn't one of those yeah this
won't win the price
the first one still might though the way
things are going that's my hope
you're hoping that the person
wait wait wait we get we get full
authorization to give this those dreams
however
i'm knocking off two points just because
of that exactly you know this is
by the way you can get those two points
back
sushi kanpai tonight
a few times
a very nice
game today fabi uh your your your play
uh through the first three rounds very
impressive um before i let you go good
one more question you got wesley
tomorrow
that's a huge game wasn't he's playing
extremely well could be 3-0 if you
hadn't messed up the first game
what what kind of fight can we expect
from you tomorrow i think i have my
double white uh so hopefully i can put
some pressure on him
um but yeah he's playing well and that's
also bad news for
uh everyone well i'm not really fighting
for first place in the grand chess tour
but uh
for everyone who who is fighting i mean
that that he's uh that he started so
well is of course not not great news
um
but anything can happen
you you're so you're going to try to
knock them off is what you're saying
i mean i'm playing white i i don't see
why not like that that's what we want to
hear all right okay well now i have one
final question uh alejandro and i uh
were stumped by a certain night ending
that sam shanklin and mvl uh were
contesting they got themselves to this
exact position
and we looked at each other mutually and
said
what's your
knee-jerk reaction to this position how
would you assess this
um
i mean i guess black plays knight f5
and white plays king d3
knight d6 and white orc okay king d7
um
maybe 96 was not good
maybe he should trip he i assume he just
didn't realize that the king and pawn on
dean is dangerous
um
turns out he has 98 here
well yeah this is really tough but you
if you if you're going to do that then
why play knight d6 why not keep the
knight on f5 and play i don't know h5 or
king e7 or something but knee-jerk
reaction oh sorry h5 loss can you force
the king e7 and if king e4 king f6 would
you say is this equal did you say is
this white's obviously better we're
close to winning
i don't think black should be losing
this
but i also think black is worse
so i don't know
objectively draw but difficult
impressive abby very very impressive we
thought that uh white had an advantage
and we thought it wasn't close in fact
that it was clearly an advantage and the
computer was just saying zero zeros
even in the game what happened in the
game right here the computer was still
zero zeros after 98 yeah this is this is
really tough though um
this move just
uh was it before the time control
yeah yeah a lot before the time control
okay well so i guess he was a bit low on
time which which really makes this a
tough it wasn't
um no this was a while ago yeah um
but it's not an easy move um he probably
also didn't realize just how
bad the king and bon ending is because
he gets in zuzuan his king needs to stay
on f6 but it can't it has to go one way
and allow king of five or the other way
in love c5
um
later they did get into a kind of a
mutual zugswong position
uh right here and we're about to take
you to the live position
and it's it's going to be one of those
queen and pawn end games where there's
like
extra queens on the board
for
uh does black get it because queen a5 is
coming so i don't think no there's no
there's no there's nothing here there's
nothing here q5 will just wrap up the
game well okay thank you five for
joining us with all of that analysis
congratulations on your current position
two and a half out of three very
impressive very impressive abby well
done well done i mean really